.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Jubel, Applaus, Stimmengewirr *
Die Schweiz hat einen neuen
Bundesrat: den Basler Beat Jans.
Die Schweiz
ist ein faszinierendes Land.
Ich habe ihn
in den vergangenen Monaten
auf dem Weg
in die Landesregierung begleitet.
Gratulation, Beat Jans!
Wie wird man Bundesrat?
Indem man zum richtigen Zeitpunkt
am richtigen Ort ist.
Ist es wirklich nicht mehr?
Als Reporter habe ich schon einige
Bundesratswahlen miterlebt Ð
oft langweilige, weil der Favorit
am Ende auch gewinnt.
Dieses Jahr ist es anders:
Das Feld der Kandidaten ist gross,
die Wahl unberechenbar.
Was macht es aus,
dass jemand Bundesrat wird?
Wie wichtig ist Lobbying?
Wie weit geht man
für die Krönung seiner Karriere?
Das finde ich heraus.
Es ist Anfang September.
Daniel Jositsch
bei seinem Morgenritual:
Westschweizer Fernsehen
und anderthalb Stunden Sport
in seiner Zweitwohnung
beim Zürcher HB.
Heute ist sein grosser Tag.
Anzug und Krawatte,
ohne geht's nicht.
Seit Jahren schon hat Daniel
Jositsch Bundesrats-Ambitionen.
Ou, ich habe
meine Notizen vergessen.
Ganz auswendig wäre nicht gut.
Wer Bundesrat werden will,
braucht ein Wahlkampfteam.
Seines hat der Rechtsprofessor
schon seit Monaten beisammen.
Im Zürcher Volkshaus
warten nicht nur Journalisten,
sondern auch Wahlkampfleiterin
Priska Seiler Graf.
Dann verkündet Daniel Jositsch,
was alle erwarten:
... dass ich für das Amt
des Bundesrates kandidieren möchte.
Die Medien
interessiert sich v.a. für eines:
die letzte Bundesratswahl,
bei der Jositsch viele SP-Kolleginnen
vor den Kopf stiess.
Sie wollten bereits letzten Winter
für den Bundesrat kandidieren,
obwohl die SP
ein reines Frauen-Ticket wollte.
Damit sind sie wohl einigen
auf die Füsse getreten.
Ist es nicht anstrengend, sich dafür
nun überall entschuldigen zu müssen?
Wird es das gleich Spiel
oder haben Sie daraus etwas gelernt?
Sie sprachen von Diskriminierung.
Machten Sie damals Fehler?
Ja, natürlich
habe ich Fehler gemacht.
Ich würde das heute nicht mehr
als Diskriminierung bezeichnen,
das war übertrieben
und auch verletzend,
insbesondere Frauen gegenüber,
die tatsächlich
diskriminiert wurden und werden.
Gut so?
Dann kann ich nämlich weitermachen.
Ja, passt. Danke, Herr Jositsch.
Beginn der Herbstsession.
Noch ist Daniel Jositsch
der einzige Bundesratskandidat.
Herr Jositsch, können wir
ein Selfie zusammen machen?- Ja.
Viel Glück noch!
- Merci.
Wer früh ins Rennen steigt,
hat ungeteilte Aufmerksamkeit.
Jositschs Taktik ist klar:
Fehler zugeben.
Die Kamera will er
bei Gesprächen nicht dabei haben.
Es ist einfach so, dass Leute dann
nicht mehr offen mit einem reden.
Auch seine Chef-Lobbyistin beginnt,
hinter den Kulissen zu arbeiten.
Da kann man sehr viel bewirken.
Meine Aufgabe sehe ich darin,
meine Fraktionskolleg/-innen
davon zu überzeugen, dass es
nicht fair ist, Daniel Jositsch
nur an seinem Verhalten
von letztem Dezember aufzuhängen,
das uns alle verärgert hat,
inklusive mich.
Man sollte ihn nicht
auf diesen Moment reduziert,
sondern sein ganzes Wirken
in Bern anschauen.
Kandidat Jositsch
geht heute zu einem Lobbyanlass
vom Verband GastroSuisse
im Berner Kornhauskeller.
Bundesrat wird man, indem man
für alle jederzeit ein Ohr hat Ð
zumindest in den paar Monaten
des Wahlkampfs.
Machen Sie diesen Anlass nur
wegen Ihrer Kandidatur?
Ganz offen gesagt, ja.
Ich lerne: Wer Bundesrat werden will,
muss Beziehungen pflegen
und vertiefen.
Es ist wichtig,
dass die Leute wissen ...
Die Beziehung zwischen Bundesrat
und Parlament ist sehr wichtig.
Dieser Zugang ist wichtig:
dass man miteinander reden
und Probleme besprechen kann.
* Feierliche Musik *
Feier zu 175 Jahren
Bundesverfassung.
Die Berner Regierungsrätin
Evi Allemann,
Jon Pult,
Sitznachbar Matthias Aebischer
und - hinten - Roger Nordmann.
Sie werden ihre Kandidatur
bald bekannt geben,
halten sich da aber noch bedeckt.
Auch Beat Jans lotet in Gesprächen
schon mal seine Chancen aus.
Bundesrat wird man,
wenn man ein gutes Timing hat.
Die Kandidatur
zum richtigen Zeitpunkt lanciert,
garantiert
viel Resonanz in den Medien.
Matthias Aebischer überrascht die
Konkurrenz mit einem frühen Start.
Ich traue mir dieses Amt zu.
Bald darauf folgen
SP-Shooting-Star Jon Pult,
Schwergewicht Roger Nordmann
und als einzige Frau
Regierungsrätin Evi Allemann.
An seine Medienkonferenz tauchen am
meisten Journalisten auf: Beat Jans.
Ich habe entschieden,
mich als Bundesrat zu bewerben.
Im Team Jans sind Basler Grössen
der nationalen Politik
und Lobbyisten
einer Kommunikationsagentur.
Vielleicht eine gute Strategie,
denn als ehemaliger Umweltaktivist
gilt Beat Jans als Bauernschreck.
Ich habe immer für die Bauern
und Bäuerinnen politisiert, immer.
Ich zog aber manchmal andere
Schlüsse als der Bauernverband.
Das Bauern-Thema wird in diesem
Wahlkampf entscheidend sein.
* Beat Jans ruft die Kühe. *
Zwei Wochen später.
Kommt!
Das Wahlkampfteam von Beat Jans
hat mich auf einen Hof
im Jura eingeladen.
Sie sind tatsächlich Bauer, das
ist jetzt nicht nur für die Kamera?
Ich habe Bauer gelernt,
ich habe
eine Lehre zum Bauer gemacht.
Ab und zu helfe ich noch aus,
aber das ist nicht mehr sehr oft.
Das fällt jetzt zufälligerweise
in die Zeit Ihrer Kandidatur?
Ja.
Ich rief die Bäuerin an -
eine langjährige Freundin von mir -
und sagte,
ich müsse jetzt Französisch lernen
im Hinblick auf die Bundesratswahl.
Und sie sagte,
sie würde mir Stunden geben,
wenn ich im Gegenzug
die Kühe melken würde,
während sie in den Ferien ist.
Das war unser Deal.
Alles ist jetzt irgendwie
Bundesratswahl.
Und so sind wir nicht die Einzigen,
die Bilder machen.
Eine Mitarbeiterin
der Kommunikationsagentur
macht Fotos vom Bauern Jans.
Vielleicht werden diese später
noch nützlich sein.
Bitte nochmals
in die Kamera schauen.
Wenn es im Wahlkampf
hart auf hart kommt und es nur noch
um das Bauern-Thema geht,
dann nehmen Sie diese Fotos hervor?
Ich weiss nicht, ob das etwas nützt.
Nicht unbedingt.
Letztlich sind Bundesräte
für alle da.
Es geht immer um ein Zusammen.
Daher muss ich nicht
eine Seite speziell betonen.
Gut. Wir werden es sehen.
Mir wird klar:
Bundesrat wird man, indem man sich
auf alle möglichen Worst-Case-
Szenarien gebührend vorbereitet.
Die Lobbyistin,
die Beat Jans begleitet,
ist eine ehemalige Angestellte
des Bauernverbandes.
Mit ihr holt sich Jans Kontakte und
viel Agrar-Fachwissen in sein Team.
Wie wichtig ist es,
dass die Agentur dabei ist?
Für mich ist es
v.a. deshalb wichtig,
weil ich noch einen Job habe.
Ich kann nicht alles selbst machen
und brauche Unterstützung.
Und ich möchte nicht, dass
die Balser Steuerzahler die Zeit,
die ich für meine
Bundesratskandidatur brauche,
finanzieren müssen.
Das ist der Hauptgrund.
Und was kostet Sie das,
vielleicht gegen 100'000 Fr.?
Nein, niemals.
- (Frau) Schön wär's.
Das zahle ich aus der eigenen
Tasche. Das würde ich nie zahlen.
Nein, nein.
Die lesen ein paar Interviews gegen,
sie beraten mich, welche Argumente
gut sind und welche schlecht.
Aber letztlich muss ich
meine Reden selbst schreiben,
denn  i c h  muss darin vorkommen.
Später erfahre ich,
dass sich Beat Jans die Agentur
rund 20'000 Fr. kosten lässt.
Er wirft sich für den Wahlkampf
in Schale.
Jon Pult gilt in der SP
als rhetorisches Supertalent.
Er ist der mit Abstand
jüngste Kandidat.
Sie sind ja der Kandidat der Jungen.
Gleichzeitig sehe ich Sie immer
in Hemd und Krawatte rumrennen.
Also so richtig für die Jungen stehen
Sie wohl auch nicht mehr, oder?
Wie schon gesagt: Mit 39
ist man nicht mehr wahnsinnig jung.
Aber ich laufe mehr
ohne Krawatten rum als mit,
ich bin ein sehr normaler Typ.
Mit ein Grund,
weshalb ich kandidiere, ist,
damit auch jemand im Bundesrat ist,
der mitten im Leben steht,
also knapp 40 ist,
und nicht nur solche um die 60.
Etwas Diversität auch diesbezüglich
wäre wohl nicht schlecht.
Seit seiner Bundesratskandidatur
wird Shooting-Star Jon Pult
auch ausserhalb Graubündens
öfter auf der Strasse angesprochen.
* Unverständliches Gespräch
auf Italienisch *
Okay. Grazie mille.
Könnten Sie mir helfen?
Ich suche einen Wintermantel.
- Ja, sehr gerne.
Das wäre eine Option,
den probiere ich mal an.
Ja, super. Was kostet der?
- Der kostet ...
Der ist 539 Fr.
- Okay.
Dann haben wir's.
500 Fr. ist aber auch nicht wenig
für einen Wintermantel.
Ja, das ist so.
Aber ich finde es
einen fairen Preis.
Bei zu günstigen Kleidern
kommen bei mir Zweifel hoch,
dass sie unter korrekten Bedingungen
hergestellt wurden.
Auch bei dem Preis
weiss ich es nicht.
Ich bin leider nicht
der bewussteste Käufer.
Aber einem zu günstigen Preis
misstraue ich.
Wenn man schon das Privileg hat,
genügend zu verdienen,
dann finde ich es auch richtig,
anständige Preis zu bezahlen.
Sie nehmen jetzt wirklich
gleich den ersten?
Da wird nicht lange gefackelt.
- Nein, der gefällt mir.
Oder der graue?
Nein, der hat keine Chance.
Ein Mann, der Chancen sofort packt -
und direkt zum höchsten Ziel strebt.
Was ich sicher nicht werden will,
ist einer dieser Politiker,
der jahrelang im Bundeshaus
herumschleicht und hofft,
irgendwann mal
diese Möglichkeit zu erhalten.
Bäh!
Sich gut zu verkaufen,
das ist Jon Pults Beruf.
In Zürich arbeitet er
als Verwaltungsrat
einer Kommunikationsagentur.
Die Mitarbeiterinnen
der eigenen Agentur Feinheit
will Pult aber für sein
Bundesratsrennen nicht einspannen.
Wahlkampfleiterin
ist seine ehemalige Sitzkollegin
aus dem Bündner Kantonsparlament,
die ehemalige Nationalrätin
Sandra Locher Benguerel.
Einerseits schaue ich, dass
mit seinen Terminen alles klappt,
weise ihn auf wichtige Anlässe hin,
gebe ihm dazu Informationen.
Meine wichtigste Aufgabe
hier im Bundeshaus ist es,
mit Leuten zu reden.
Bundesrat wird,
wer Bedenken zerstreuen kann
und Wählerstimmen holt.
* Unverständliches Gespräch *
Beat Jans nutzt jede Gelegenheit,
ins Bundeshaus zu kommen.
Denn seit 2020
politisiert er nicht mehr in Bern.
Mit einigen
habe ich schon Termine abgemacht,
bei anderen melde ich mich spontan,
dass ich hier bin.
Einen Badge hat er keinen mehr.
Er muss via Besuchereingang rein.
Die Sicherheitsleute
kennen mich noch
und machen mir die Tür auf.
Wahnsinn!
Ziel ist,
nun möglichst viele SP-Kolleginnen
auf seine Seite zu ziehen
und Einblick in die Taktik
der Mitkonkurrenten zu erhalten.
* Feierlicher Gesang *
Es ist der letzte Sessionstag
der Legislatur,
eine grosse Abschlussfeier steht an.
Beat Jans hat organisiert,
dass er als Schlagzeuger
in der Parlaments-Band Fraktionszwang
mitspielen darf,
wie früher als Nationalrat.
Eine hervorragende Gelegenheit,
für sich selbst
die Werbetrommel zu rühren.
Abends dann rauschende Party
im Bundeshaus.
Filmen ist nicht erlaubt.
* Flotte Musik *
Doch eine Parlamentarierin stellt
den Auftritt von Beat Jans online.
Im Getümmel versucht
auch die Konkurrenz zu netzwerken.
Du hättest noch ein Gesangssolo
machen können oder so.
Ich glaube, man kann keine
Werbung in eigener Sache machen.
Man kann einfach
mit den Leuten sprechen,
und die Leute aus der Fraktion
kennen einen.
Daher ist es
eine relativ offene Situation.
Die Leute halten sich auch bedeckt.
Sie sind sehr zurückhaltend,
wenn man mit ihnen redet.
Meine Einschätzung lautet,
dass alles noch offen ist.
Am Ende darf ich trotzdem noch
kurz in den Saal,
wo die Politiker
sonst unter sich sind.
Kann es sein,
dass es manchen komisch vorkommt,
dass Sie hier plötzlich
Schlagzeug spielen?
Das kann sein.
Es gibt immer Leute,
die etwas nicht gut finden.
Aber mir hat es
grossen Spass gemacht.
Ich durfte ja vor vier Jahren schon
mal, es fühlte sich vertraut an.
Für die nun anstehenden Hearings
hat sich Jon Pult warm angezogen,
mit dem neuen Mantel.
Je näher die Entscheidung kommt,
desto grösser ist das Risiko,
einen Fehler zu begehen
als noch etwas zu bewegen.
Es geht jetzt also v.a. darum,
keine Fehler zu machen,
nichts Blödes zu sagen, das dann
in den Zeitungen zitiert wird?
Ja, einerseits das,
aber auch generell ...
Die wichtigste Aufgabe
in einer Kampagne
wie auch sonst
in der Politik ist es,
sich selbst treu zu bleiben.
Jon Pult setzt auf Ehrlichkeit.
Auf dem Weg zum Hearing in Biel
trifft er zufällig Konkurrentin
Evi Allemann.
Evi, tschau.
Fahrt ihr erste Klasse?
- Ich fahre erste Klasse, und du?
Dann also alle.
Die Gruppe
beschränkt sich auf Small Talk.
Solange die Kamera läuft,
will man um keinen Preis
eine heikle Aussage riskieren.
Umso angespannter die Situation,
als sich plötzlich
eine Sitznachbarin einschaltet.
Für mich ist Biel Marseille Süd:
viele Probleme, viele Ausländer.
Wir schauen zu wenig
zu unseren Leuten.
Sorry, aber ich sah,
wie meine Eltern
jeden Rappen umdrehen mussten.
Das finde ich ungerecht.
Warum haben unsere Leute
keinen Vortritt?
Während Evi Allemann zuhört,
wagt sich Jon Pult an eine Antwort.
Weil wir alle Leute
gleich behandeln Ð
das ist eine wichtige Schweizer
Errungenschaft.
Wir versuchen, nächstes Jahr
eine 13. AHV-Rente durchzusetzen.
Für alle.
Der richtige Auftritt
steht erst noch bevor.
Sandy!
- Hey!
Magst du Marroni?
- Ja, gerne.
Es ist eine der vier
schweizweiten SP-Roadshows.
Dieses öffentliche Hearing findet
vorwiegend vor SP-Mitgliedern statt,
aber da die Medien
breit berichten werden,
sind die Auftritte wichtig für die
Grundstimmung in der Öffentlichkeit.
(Frau) JUSO oder SP 60+?
- Prospektivisch SP 60+.
* Lachen *
Jon Pult hat das sehr gut gemacht.
- Jon Pult.
Herr Pult hat mir sehr gut gefallen.
Team Jon Pult holt den Tagessieg.
Aber auch der Kampagnenleiter
von Beat Jans ist zufrieden,
auch weil sein Kandidat
viele Kontakte knüpft.
Das Wichtigste
ist der Einzelkontakt.
In der Fraktion
sind etwas über 40 Leute.
Beat hat den Anspruch,
mit jedem persönlich zu reden
und einzeln in Austausch zu kommen.
Das läuft ziemlich gut,
auch weil er viele Leute noch kennt.
Wo es Lücken gibt,
unterstützen wir ihn,
um Gelegenheiten
für einen Austausch zu schaffen.
Es gilt, neue Kontakte zu knüpfen.
Denn das Bundeshaus
wurde gerade neu besetzt.
57 neu gewählte Parlamentarier
tummeln sich
unter der Bundeshauskuppel.
Die Neulinge
haben heute ihren ersten Tag.
Darunter 15 SP-Leute.
Seit ihrer Wahl wurden sie
von den Bundesratskandidaten
intensiv umschwärmt.
Das war noch lustig.
Jemand rief gleich an,
andere schickten eine E-Mail,
teils sehr allgemein,
teils auf mich abgestimmt.
Ich ging mit jemandem
Kaffee trinken,
mit jemand anderem am See spazieren,
mit einigen habe ich telefoniert.
Einige kamen sehr kollegial
auf mich zu,
andere sehr professionell,
wo es auch ganz klar
um die Bundesratswahl ging.
Nichts versprochen,
nichts geschenkt.
Nein. Das waren persönliche
und gute Gespräche.
Am selben Tag: die erste SP-
Fraktionssitzung in neuer Besetzung.
Noch einmal suchen die Kandidaten
den Kontakt zu den Neuen.
In dieser Sitzung wird entschieden,
dass die SP
auf ein Zweier-Ticket setzt.
Und so langsam zeichnet sich auch ab,
wer erfolgreich lobbyiert hat.
Wie lief das Lobbieren
für Herrn Jositsch?
Es wird für ihn nicht einfach.
Das ist kein Geheimnis,
das habe ich auch herausgespürt.
Und ich bin auch nicht sicher, ob
einem alle immer die Wahrheit sagen.
Die Sozialdemokraten
werden am nächsten Tag
die zwei offiziellen Kandidaten
wählen.
Beim Abendessen in einer Berner Beiz
legen die Lager der einzelnen
Kandidaten ihre Taktik zurecht.
Heute gilt es ernst.
Nun zeigt sich,
wer die meisten Stimmen bekommt
und es auf das Zweier-Ticket schafft.
Es ist schon ein wichtiger Tag
im Leben, aber es kommt gut.
Beruflich wohl der wichtigste Tag
im Leben bisher?
Vielleicht, so kann man's sagen.
Eine letzte Frage?
Ich bin gespannt.
Zu favorisiert zu sein,
ist eher gefährlich.
Ich bin zuversichtlich und
nehme das Resultat so wie es kommt.
Wer hat am besten lobbyiert?
Wer am schlausten taktiert?
Und wer die meisten überzeugt?
Während draussen der Winter einsetzt,
versuchen alle Kandidierenden
hinter verschlossenen Türen,
die Fraktion mit einem kurzen Referat
zu überzeugen.
Wie lief es?
- Gut. Alles gut.
Wie lief das Bewerbungsgespräch
Ihres Lebens?
Ich weiss es nicht,
das müssen die da drin entscheiden.
Dann beginnt ein Wahlmarathon,
der sich über fast 3 Std.
hinziehen wird.
Immer wieder
werden Stimmen ausgezählt Ð
offensichtlich setzen sich
die vermeintlichen Favoriten
nicht so schnell durch wie erwartet.
Die Journalisten
werden zunehmend ungeduldig.
* Enttäuschte Laute *
Erst nach 18 Wahlgängen hat die SP
ein offizielles Bundesrats-Ticket:
Jon Pult und Beat Jans.
Herr Jositsch,
woran ist es gescheitert?
Warum kein Kommentar?
Für Daniel Jositsch
ist der Bundesrats-Traum
wohl ein für alle Mal ausgeträumt.
Die nächsten Wochen
wird er zum Thema schweigen.
Das Resultat war knapp.
Es hat auch mit Glück zu tun.
Aber damit muss man leben können.
Das Leben geht weiter,
auch das politische. Ade!
Die einen treten von der Bühne.
Für die anderen
geht es jetzt richtig los.
Nach der eigenen Fraktion
müssen sie jetzt versuchen,
die Mehrheit der Bundesversammlung
zu überzeugen.
Doch zuerst wartet eine
gigantische Flut von Medienanfragen.
Ich würde gerne noch was bestellen.
Einen Ingwertee.
Ich muss maximale Abwehr aufbauen.
Tschau!
Grüezi.
- Viel Glück für morgen.- Danke.
Das ist unser Regierungszimmer.
Das ist mein Sitz
als Regierungspräsident.
Für Beat Jans und Jon Pult beginnt
nun ein Schaulaufen bei den Medien.
Ein sog. Midlifer ...
- Haben Sie einen Knaller für mich?
Sie propagieren ja
eine Annäherung an die EU.
Jetzt geht es darum, als Linker
bis weit ins bürgerliche Lager hinein
wählbar zu werden.
Ich muss schauen, nicht zu sehr
einzufallen. Das sagt man mir immer.
Heute steht ein wichtiges Hearing an:
beim mächtigen Bauernverband.
Darum lässt sich Beat Jans
von der Landwirtschafts-Expertin
seiner Agentur
nochmals fachliche Inputs
und ein letztes Briefing geben.
Die Spezialistin hat für seine Rede
einen Entwurf geschrieben,
den er für sich umschreibt.
Beat Jans will
auf die Bauern zugehen.
Er ist bereit, seine radikalen
Positionen infrage zu stellen.
Ich will den Bauern
eine Tür aufmachen und sagen:
Die ökologischen Ziele, für die ich
mich immer einsetzte, sind wichtig.
Die sollten wir erreichen,
und zwar zusammen.
Wir sollten pragmatischen Massnahmen
beschliessen
sowie Ausnahmen zulassen, damit
die Bauern das umsetzen können.
Und dann habe ich noch
ein Geschenk dabei.
Während Beat Jans mit seinen Basler
Läckerli in einem "Chriesichratte"
siegessicher ins Hearing zieht,
ist Jon Pult nervös.
Am Tag wurde
über ein Video berichtet,
das Pults Werbeagentur
vor Jahren im Auftrag
von Umweltverbänden gemacht hat.
Hat Ihr Gegner
das den Medien gesteckt?
Ich weiss es nicht. Ich gehe davon
aus, dass die Journalist/-innen
wie immer ihre Arbeit
korrekt machten.
Die bäuerlichen Parlamentarier
erwarten,
dass Pult sich
für das Video entschuldigt.
Beat Jans kommt mit seiner kompro-
missbereiten Haltung derweil gut an.
Haben Sie sich entschuldigt?
Es gibt keinen Grund
für eine Entschuldigung.
Ich wiederhole es nochmals: Das war
eine Auftragsarbeit der Agentur,
bei der ich Verwaltungsrat bin.
Ein Unternehmen,
das eine Dienstleistung erbringt,
muss sich doch nicht
mit einer Person in Dialog setzen,
die wütend ist wegen einer Kampagne,
die jemand anderes
zu verantworten hat.
Gut. Merci beaucoup,
mes nouveaux amis.
* Lachen *
Der Kommunikationsprofi weiss:
Dieses Hearing
könnte ihn die Wahl gekostet haben.
Beginn der Wintersession Ð
noch neun Tage bis zur Wahl.
Gerüchte, allenthalben Ð
auch von wilden Kandidaten.
Mittendrin: die Lobbyisten
der beiden Wahlkampfteams.
Nun gilt es, die Fühler zu den
anderen Parteien auszustrecken.
Jeder einzelne Parlamentarier
wird bearbeitet.
Wichtig sind jetzt feine Antennen,
um zu spüren, wie die Stimmung ist,
um bis zum 13. Dezember
noch reagieren zu können.
Zu fragen, was es denn war,
das bei jemandem vielleicht
eine Gegenreaktion auslöste.
Das ist eine gute Basis
für ein Gespräch,
um dann über die Qualitäten
von Jon Pult zu sprechen.
Das Team Pult versucht aufzuholen -
und das Team Jans
will sich nicht einholen lassen.
Die Nacht der langen Messer Ð
Vorabend zum Wahltag.
Das Bellevue ist ab 21.30 Uhr
zum Bersten voll.
Rund 100 Politiker und mindestens
doppelt so viele Journalisten
und Zaungäste tummeln sich
im Foyer und in der Bar.
Konnte Team Pult
in den letzten Tagen noch aufholen?
Ja, ganz sicher.
Die Aktie Pult ist
in den letzten Tagen noch gestiegen.
Ob es reichen wird für morgen,
das werden wir sehen.
Aber wir haben bis zuletzt
unser Bestmöglichtest gegeben.
Und das ist das Wichtigste.
Die Nacht der langen Messer
ist wohl v.a. ein Mythos.
Die Würfel
sind vermutlich bereits gefallen.
Alle Szenarien sind geschrieben,
alle Pläne gemacht,
morgen kann es losgehen.
Ich glaube, es wird Beat Jans,
auch wenn niemand so wirklich
glücklich ist mit ihm,
v.a. die Bürgerlichen nicht.
So spannend wie es medial abge-
handelt wird, wird es morgen nicht.
Wird es eine langweilige Wahl?
Nein, mich langweilig.
Es ist eine wichtige Wahl,
aber einfach
keine Wahl mit Überraschungen.
Also Jans oder Pult.
Nein, nein, es wird Jans.
Kein Bundesrat Pult.
Kein Zweifel beim Urgestein
der Politanalyse,
was morgen im Bundeshaus
passieren wird.
Wahltag.
Es war eine intensive, lehrreiche,
aber auch schöne Zeit.
Und heute entscheidet
die vereinigte Bundesversammlung.
Sie klingen nicht zuversichtlich.
- Doch, ich bin zuversichtlich.
Wie sieht es aus?
50:50.
- 50:50?
Was das Medieninteresse angeht, liegt
Beat Jans jedenfalls klar vorne.
Die Fraktionen
treffen sich zu letzten Sitzungen.
Die Spannung steigt.
Und dann geht alles ganz schnell.
Nach nur drei Wahlgängen
ist es entschieden.
(Mann) Majorité absolue: 134.
Gewählt ist mit 134 Stimmen:
Beat Jans.
* Jubel *
Der Favorit hat sich durchgesetzt,
seine Strategie ist aufgegangen.
Und ein bisschen Glück
war wohl auch dabei.
Ich erkläre Annahme der Wahl.
Danke.
* Applaus, Jubel *
Untertitelung: Sucevic Solutions
im Auftrag von SWISS TXT - 2023